PRIYANKA: Welcome to
"Get Cooking in Cloud,"
where we share the best recipes
to apply in your cloud kitchen.
I'm Priyanka, and the
next few episodes,
we will talk about mobile
app backend solutions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So today I've invited
Jen Person to the kitchen
to show us how to get cooking
with the mobile app backend.
Jen, thank you so
much for coming.
JEN: My pleasure, Priyanka.
I've brought an appetizing
solution with me today.
PRIYANKA: Ah, amazing.
And actually, I've
got an app that I
would like to try this on.
It's called
"Priyanka's Kitchen,"
and it's a cooperative
cooking game for mobile.
JEN: I love that kind of game.
PRIYANKA: Me too.
And apparently lots of
other folks like it too.
"Priyanka's Kitchen"
is experiencing
a tremendous growth
in App Store and Play
Store, which is awesome, but
I'm seeing a huge increase
in the number of files
my app needs to store
and the amount of data
I need to quickly sync
between multiple users.
It seems mobile has
its own challenges.
Can you help cook up
such a backend service?
JEN: That's a great
question, Priyanka.
Most mobile apps and games
need a backend service
for things that can't be done
solely on device, like sharing
and processing data
from multiple users,
or storing large files.
PRIYANKA: Very true.
But here on "Get
Cooking in Cloud,"
we've shown a lot of
backend service solutions.
What's different about
a mobile backend?
JEN: You're absolutely right.
Building a backend
service for a mobile app
is similar to building
a web-based service.
But there are some
additional requirements.
First, it's important to
limit on-device data storage.
Storage on mobile
devices is limited.
Users need to be able to use
their storage space the way
that they want to.
PRIYANKA: For dog
pictures and memes.
[LAUGHING]
JEN: Next, a mobile
backend service
needs to synchronize data
across multiple devices.
When playing a mobile
game with friends,
your moves need to sync up
across everyone's devices.
PRIYANKA: Lags
and jitters aren't
acceptable for mobile games,
especially when I'm winning.
[LAUGHING]
JEN: And we know that the
quality of mobile networks
varies greatly.
So mobile apps need
to assume times
with limited or no connectivity,
handling that offline case
gracefully.
PRIYANKA: I think
I'm getting a handle
of these mobile
backend differences,
like how mobile devices
and services need to send
notifications and messages.
JEN: Exactly.
PRIYANKA: And of
course, mobile backends
should minimize battery drain.
JEN: You got it.
So as you can see, there
are some key requirements
we have to consider.
And I've cooked up a few
different design patterns
to demonstrate ways to
use Google Cloud Platform
to address these requirements.
For today's recipe, I
brought along some Firebase.
PRIYANKA: Sounds spicy.
JEN: Doesn't it?
Even though Firebase sounds
like just one ingredient,
it definitely isn't
a bland solution.
Firebase is a fully
managed platform
for building iOS,
Android, and web apps.
It provides automatic
data synchronization,
authentication services,
messaging, file storage,
analytics, and more.
PRIYANKA: So starting
with Firebase
seems to be an efficient
way to build or prototype
mobile backend services.
Now, when is a good
time to serve Firebase?
Family dinners?
Weddings?
Friday parties?
Birthday parties?
[LAUGHING]
JEN: Yes.
Firebase is great for
a last-minute dinner.
You can develop your app
quickly because Firebase client
SDKs simplify getting backend
services up and running.
But I recommend
Firebase for all sorts
of mobile back indications.
Firebase products
are designed to scale
so you can use them seamlessly
from prototype to production
to top app, like
"Priyanka's Kitchen."
PRIYANKA: So why is Firebase
a great backend solution,
especially for mobile apps?
JEN: Well, Firebase addresses
a lot of the unique needs
of mobile apps.
It's great at limiting
on-device space usage when
you manage key value
data in Cloud Firestore
and files in cloud
storage for Firebase.
It makes sending notifications
and data messages a snap
with Firebase Cloud Messaging.
It offers automated real-time
data synchronization
across multiple devices.
It gracefully handles
the offline case
and offers
authentication of users
through a variety of
identity providers.
PRIYANKA: Firebase
sounds like an out
of the box solution for many
mobile app backend needs.
I can't wait to
try it out myself.
But before making Firebase
my backend solution
for "Priyanka's Kitchen,"
is there anything
else I should know?
JEN: Yes.
So I don't always
recommend Firebase
for apps that need
a backend service
to modify the synchronized data.
PRIYANKA: Hm.
That's interesting.
Give me an example.
JEN: Firebase
products handle a lot
of the heavy backend
lifting for you.
So you don't have to build
some features yourself.
But there are still
situations where
you may need to modify
data outside of the client.
For example, if "Priyanka's
Kitchen" keeps a leaderboard,
you'll want to run the code
to rank users in a server.
PRIYANKA: That's true.
I do need to keep the
leaderboard up to date.
But Firebase does have server
SDKs called the admin SDKs.
Does Firebase have
a server solution
in which to use these SDKs?
JEN: That's a great question.
Well, one of the many
Firebase products
is a serverless solution called
Cloud Functions for Firebase.
Cloud Functions let
you automatically
run backend code in
response to events
triggered by Firebase
features and HTTPS requests.
You can use the admin
SDKs in a Cloud Function
to modify the synchronized
data, among other tasks.
PRIYANKA: So I could use Cloud
Functions to update user ranks?
JEN: Yes, you certainly can.
But as your app
grows, this can get
more challenging to run
from a Cloud Function.
PRIYANKA: Ah, so let me guess.
Is it because Cloud
Functions are short-lived?
JEN: You guessed it.
Cloud Functions are short-lived.
So if you have a small amount
of user scores to process,
you can rank them quickly
before the function tears down.
But when you have
lots of user scores
to analyze, say,
hundreds of thousands,
then a long-running
server is a better fit.
In that case, Firebase
alone will not
be a complete solution.
I'll talk about that
recipe another day.
PRIYANKA: Aw, you're killing me.
Wow, you are right.
Firebase isn't a
bland solution at all.
It seems like
there's a lot to it,
so it can be hard to picture.
I would love to see
what a complete Firebase
solution looks like.
JEN: Well, I just happen to have
a completed Firebase solution
right here.
Here you can see a diagram
of our design pattern.
And right here is Friendly Pix.
It's a sample app
that features examples
of how to use many
different Firebase products.
PRIYANKA: Looks amazing.
So what should our
viewers at home
do if they would like to cook
up their own Firebase app?
JEN: You can check out the
guides, reference docs,
code examples on GitHub, and
the Firebase YouTube channel.
PRIYANKA: There
you have it, folks.
That's all for today on
"Get Cooking in Cloud."
Here's hoping you can
whip up something great.
Join us next time because Jen
will be coming back to show us
another tasty mobile
app backend solution.
If you liked this
video and would
like to see more
of such content,
don't forget to like and
subscribe to our channel!
[MUSIC PLAYING]